an der zürcher bahnhofstrasse von außen
nicht erkennbar öffnet nach ladenschluss
das restaurant von sami churi ich möchte
dass die leute im auto kann dies brachte
und für seine gastro projekte sind
verblüffend was ihn vom rest ab hebel
seien bessere ideen
[Musik]
zwei wochen vorher kurios sein team
bauen in diesem leeren
spielwarengeschäft ein komplettes
restaurant auf als zwischennutzung für
sechs wochen seit zehn jahren kreierte
temporäre lokale in ungewöhnlichen
räumen in kellern einer ehemaligen bank
einem leeren kinder
man nennt ihn den underground gastronom
seine lokale pop up restaurants beides
mager nicht ich will sich mit
gastronomen sie das ist immer dasselbe
freiwillig selbst geschreinert der nacht
antwort das ist also das aufzugs- und
damit verschärft wird und sagt wo
emotionen auslösen und das ist das wo
immer in kontakt mit alkohol bringt
nämlich wieder zurück
er ist ein mittler und mache kury war 20
und kameraassistent als er anfing
nebenbei mit gebrauchten gegenständen
und chromstahl teilen zu handeln
in seiner lagerhalle begann er für seine
freunde meist aus der alternativen szene
zu kochen
so entstand die idee in kellern halt
illegale temporäre lokale aufzubauen
bald erhielt der aufträge von firmen
galerien und privatpersonen aus der
ganzen schweiz
sein team ist bis heute dasselbe
geblieben freunde und kollegen
das ist ihm wichtig und freut ihn der
enge kern sind seine freundin carolin
gomez sein jugendfreund schuhe hoffmann
und kurs ältere schwester die japaner
insgesamt hat der junge unternehmer 28
befreundete angestellte bezahlen und
freunde und der motor bin eigentlich da
hand wird zieht meine dachlinie bauer
und jede idee das ist dann ist die welt
und dann muss man sowieso und das
trinken und andere ist nur wenn die show
und die schau unter dem leben beten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die eröffnung des temporären restaurants
wie immer sind kuris lokale aufwendig
dekoriert zum 5 gang menü gibt es
ausgefallene chance einlass gibt es für
die die seine handynummer besitzen und
per sms reserviert haben was kury macht
wird zum stadtgespräch
[Applaus]
wir treffen ihn im multikulturellen
langstrassenquartier bei seiner
imbissbude palast im griff
das war sein erstes offizielles
restaurant
das hat sich zufälligerweise durch einen
gastronomen ergeben zusammen
[Applaus]
sie haben geben wir doch mal loszulassen
einfach zum spaß
die rezepte sind von seiner mutter sami
churi ist in der schweiz geboren seine
eltern waren aus palästina und jordanien
eingewandert 500 user sind in einiger
zeit zu dem konflikt
ich habe mir dann irgendwann über leid
wenn man das zukunftskonzept vor praxis
es gibt ja ein es gibt verlassen wir uns
verlaufen
das haben wie bei der wunder also dass
israel ist jude
alisa gezielte finanzmärkte verlaufen
dann haben wir das abi das ist ja
aubergine zitiert dies kurz mit rumba so
dass ich eine nummer aus tel aviv du
bist ja da habe ich es ist gut und alle
zusammen
freilich für prinz bleibt wochenfrist
und das x10 auf seiner mannschaft
spielten sie stolz und ich bin auch ich
bin auch eine finanz und jordanien
eine andere schwitzen sich erdgas
premier versuche ich mit der lüge und
viele haben also wenn ein artikel
erschienen
ich habe gut wie viele der oft so ist
verpflichtet die staaten helfen
das wird also nicht so verhasst
in seinem leben ergibt das eine das
nächste budget pläne sind ihm fremd
mit diesem grill gründer der sami churi
seine firma märz amigo und family seine
familie ist ihm wichtig
kury auf dem weg zu seinen eltern hier
in zürich ist der 30 jährige
aufgewachsen familie das wichtigste
familie ist einfach der halt und was man
weiß dass vereinbar ist und mitte und
schlachtet die eltern sind in den
siebziger jahren in die schweiz gekommen
sein vater arbeitete als physiotherapeut
seine mutter ist seit 23 jahren
kinderhort leiterin von klein auf war
sami churi immer für eine überraschung
gut
[Musik]
die schule interessierte ihn weniger er
machte viel blödsinn und musste die
schule wechseln
richtig schwierig wurde es für die
familie als er im achten schuljahr als
und schulbau von der schule flog sie
also ist eigentlich in sachsen wird so
vereint auch ingenieure hose ist so
unklar des lebens macht sowieso
aber für mich ist sie ja nicht ständig
fragen sie dann also hat neulich gelernt
die uns so und und material gefüllt dann
sortiert wird also im nach hatte
[Gelächter]
plötzlich einfach unerwartet erwartet
einfach als verräterisch nicht einfach
sie überhaupt nicht obwohl haben wir
viermal älterer spieler kommt somit den
mit der lehrerin und so und einfach von
anfang an eine gute lehre mich vergisst
sie nie hat sie gemerkt dass einfach so
starke bilder und ich muss kaiser gehört
der zukunft an ihm und muss man immer
glauben und so war es dann auch obwohl
er keinen schulabschluss hat fand der
eine lehrstelle als siebdrucker und als
müsste er es allen beweisen legte er so
richtig los seine familie arbeitete von
anfang an bei seinen projekten mit
oftmals schön
ab und zu ist schwierig natürlich ob ihr
leben schluss kommt finde ich das
eigentlich sehr kurz ist so handke das
wird eben alles einfacher machen oder
sagen andere diskutieren geschichte die
ich schon mit der familie aber jetzt mit
angestellten zum bezug hat will ich
seine familie ist sein team und sein
team seine familie im büro der firma
amigo und family in diesem kleinen raum
werden die großen ideen geboren seit
zwei monaten arbeiten sie am größten
projekt des jahres einen boxkampf event
gute morgen nochmal crew die gäste vom
militär bestreitet am dienstag auf die
elfe mit das auto geholt
kury lässt nicht gerne den chef
raushängen
alle wissen was zu tun ist
auf seine freundin karen gomez kann sich
sowieso verlassen
sie hält die stellung wenn er unterwegs
ist ist freundschaft und wir sehen wir
was passiert ist
der boxkampf event findet in einer
großen halle in zürich statt
[Musik]
er hatte ein großes netzwerk von der
alternativen szene bis zur prominenz er
gilt als freundlicher kerl den alle
mögen rapper stress probt seinen
auftritt
das heißt dass es sich um zwei
geschwister machen noch mehr bewegung
sowohl wenn man noch holen
jedes neue projekt soll das vorherige
übertreffen das ist seine devise und
sein team muss dahinter stehen können
alle arbeiten mit leib und seele vor
sieben jahren veranstaltete er den
ersten boxkampf anlass in einem keller
für 200 freunde
heute ist es ein grossanlass für 1200
gäste insgesamt sind 300 mitarbeiter im
einsatz
25 davon sind köche trotz dieser
kommerziellen größe ist es wichtig
seinen werten treu und unabhängig zu
bleiben
so schafft es so gern für die sammel
linie sind wir darauf freuen der note
und es schafft sich aufkleber mitglied
wo man gerne abgeschafft und wir sind
förmlich wie macht der das freut die
hand und nicht irgendwie aus geldgründen
sind also mir ist gerne ganz gern
spektakulär ist auch und sache wohl
nicht ganz normal sind macht spaß
wichtig ist zu allererst und so alle
lüth woche mit sind wie medizin das
mache eine bezahlte jahre hat noch darum
staatsaufbau somit ein augenzeuge als
thema familie durchbringen
und jetzt
damit ist in der regel auch die wellen
starke und mystery adventure sagte ich
glaube jetzt sehr langsam die munition
wer sich jetzt so die letzte zwei
stunden laufen und details was man kurz
war das wasser kontrolliert weil das
personal kronen damit alle briefe und
die halle stattfindet ist eine hand wir
sind der export oder song co
auch die eltern halfen mit aber am abend
sind die gäste in einer viertelstunde
ist eines
jetzt geht die luft
die tiere sind auch sei jetzt noch nicht
parat
die gäste wissen nicht was auf sie
zukommt
sie erhielten nur eine sms mit einer
zeit und ortsangaben
[Applaus]
das thema eine autonome welt in der
gangster sagen haben
[Applaus]
die einzelnen boxer ziehen in begleitung
von autonomen gruppen ein
mitglieder eines mexikanischen
drogenkartells zum beispiel oder
fußballfans
wieder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die extravaganten show einlagen und das
gourmet essen begeistern die gäste ein
wenig freude darüber sieht man curri und
seinem team an
auch wenn sie nonstop am rotieren sind
ich weiß wie lange ich noch mit
trinkwasser beziehen
der event ist eine art visitenkarte der
firma egal wie hoch die kosten sind
hauptsache er wird in aller munde sein
[Musik]
der höhepunkt sind die boxkämpfe es gibt
fünf kämpfe professionell durchgezogen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gutes zeichen
kury geht an seine grenzen mit allem was
er macht und wie er es macht
der boxkampf anlass war ein voller
erfolg finanziell aber nicht die kosten
wurden nicht gedeckt aber das ist in
ordnung für kuri der gute ruf zeit mehr
und machen es ist eine gratwanderung
denn cool faktor behalten und rechnungen
bezahlen können
das underground image aufrecht erhalten
und kommerziellen erfolgreich sein
kuri ist unternehmer er hat angestellte
und fixe kosten und am ende möchte auch
er geld verdienen
er ist an einem entscheidenden punkt
angelangt was kommt als nächstes
jedes mal wieder zu rufen hamburg sie
sind die damen aber es muss so spitze
wir ihn kriegen auch noch finanzielle
dinge sind abbauen
während andere einmal pause nach 20
jahren ausgeliefert aber wir haben sie
ein neues spiel neues bad neues logo und
schon mega druck und haben immer so
nötig sie riskiert man unbedingt merken
aber wird jemand sie zu mögen wir uns
anderen meters ein paar monate später
treffen wir ihn wieder
er wagt den sprung ins kalte wasser er
übernimmt fix ein restaurant am see
sonst aber bleibt alles beim alten
familie und freunde zuerst
unabhängigkeit und gestalterische
freiheiten garantieren
chronische lengerich braucht und dass
das ganz frisch
das reise mit dem rechten rand und dass
dieses christian 115 mal gemacht und es
fehlt sie und kulturelle business machen
unternehmer cory führt eine
verantwortung gegenüber seiner familie
seinen freunden und angestellten
[Gelächter]
er möchte ihnen ein regelmäßiges
einkommen garantieren können
ich habe schöne und harmonische freund
ich sehe meine rolle sieht 14 gesehen
und mir alle geologischen geschichte zu
sein und trotzdem in sozialer und ich
hoffe dass alles sauber finanziert und
und dass ich dir aber dass ich mit einem
zähler blieben und aber in fahrt und ich
möchte und so weiter und es gibt
natürlich ganz viele und ich im kopf
habe ich will das was passiert und das
einfache das ist eigentlich das ganz
große ziel und aufgabe
mit leuten zusammen zu arbeiten die ihm
am herzen liegen
unabhängig zu bleiben und immer einen
schritt voraus zu sein
das macht sami churi erfolgreich und
einzigartig das permanente restaurants
auch nicht stillstand bedeuten denn wohl
wie immer wird sami churi eine idee
haben und es wird aus einer das nächste
ergeben
[Musik]